foreign
[Music]
you will learn about Auto tuning
features and how to troubleshoot one of
the common issues related to Auto tuning
in Cloud dataflow
Auto tuning isn't just a way to make you
sound like a better singer when
recording music it's also featuring
cloud data flow to help execute your job
as quickly and efficiently as possible
including horizontal Auto scaling
vertical Auto scaling and dynamic work
rebalancing let's start by looking at
each of these features in more detail
horizontal Auto scaling is a feature
that automatically chooses the
appropriate number of work instances
required to run your job and dynamically
adds or removes workers as appropriate
vertical Auto scaling dynamically scales
up or down the memory available to
workers to fit the requirements of the
job this feature makes the jobs
resilient to out-of-memory errors and to
maximize pipeline efficiency finally
Dynamic work rebalancing dynamically
assigns work to unused or underused
workers
to decrease your jobs overall processing
time this is accomplished by
automatically detecting certain
conditions including imbalances in work
assignments or workers finishing faster
or slower than expected it's helpful to
note that while vertical Auto scaling is
suitable for streaming jobs Dynamic work
rebalancing is well matched to batch
shops where right feeding happens for
the workload while these Auto tuning
features help to dynamically optimize
your data flow job there are times when
they may fail or not work as expected
today I will show you how to
troubleshoot and resolve one of the
common issues with all tuning in cloud
data flow data flow workers for
streaming jobs aren't scaling down
enough though the average CPU
utilization stays below 75 percent to
investigate this issue first validate if
the following criteria has been met for
scaling down is the CPU utilization of
all the workers less than 75 five
percent for two or more minutes and is
the streaming pipeline backlog lower
than 10 seconds which is the default
criteria next check if you are using the
streaming engine if the job is not using
the streaming engine then be aware that
dataflow requires each worker to have
the same number of persistent disks with
a maximum of 15 disks per worker and
this could be affecting its ability to
Auto scale for example if there are 60
disks and 60 workers then each worker
will have one disk
let's say the job scales down to 30
workers each worker will now have two
disks
however the maximum number of disks a
worker can have is 15. this means data
flow cannot scale down below 4 workers
because this is the point at which each
of the workers would be owning 15 disks
thus if you are observing the streaming
job is not scaling down then it is
because each worker has reached the
maximum number of risks they can hold
hence data flow workers cannot scale
down any further even if the CPU
utilization is low to address this issue
use the streaming engine data flow
streaming engine moves pipeline
execution out of the worker VMS and into
the dataflow service backend
hence you will see the following
benefits with streaming engine
reduction in consumed CPU memory and
persistent disk storage resources on the
worker VMS more responsive horizontal
Auto scaling in response to variations
in incoming data volume
streaming engine offers smoother more
granular scaling of workers
for more information about streaming
engine check out this documentation hope
you found this video useful to learn
about all tuning features and
troubleshoot a common issue observed
with auto tuning do not miss the next
episode where we will share more tips on
troubleshooting another common Auto
tuning issue stay tuned for more
information about alternating features
in data flow check out the following
documentation
foreign
[Music]